joining us right now from the Bay Area
he's gonna call tonight's pelicans
warriors game 5 on ESPN radio back here
in the Rich Eisen show PJ Carlesimo how
are you PJ excellent rich how are you I
am doing fine what do you think of the
chances of New Orleans somehow someway
getting off the mat here this evening
well I want to be fair to Alvin Gentry
and his team there they've had a great
year Alvin I'd say hopefully he's got
his contract extended and hopefully it's
going to go a lot longer I mean they
picked up his option but hopefully he's
going to get a longtime deal out it is
because he deserves it but they're in
the wrong place at the wrong time Golden
State is playing I think as well as
they've played all year Steph Curry's
getting more healthy every time he plays
which is important and it's interesting
because he needs the games to get
athlete's they're not doing anything in
practice right now you just can't
simulate it practice particularly this
time of the year what he needs to get
himself you know back in the kind of
shape it'd be where he playing day and
day out so all things are go for the
lawyers including the fact that they've
won 14 straight at Oracle over the last
two years in the playoffs oh no
tough tough order tonight for New
Orleans I never say never but this is
that where you want to be the Warriors
have been through this before they know
how important it is in a playoff Chuck
Daly used to always say you don't want
to play extra games in the playoff so I
think the Warriors will take care of
business they'll find a way to get it
done and get ready for that next round
well in terms of that then the Cavs are
not going to play any extra games in the
playoffs to use the Chuck Daly
I guess analogy exactly so let me ask
you this question because you know and
I'm not one of those guys that's just
tries to find the one negative in a sea
of positives for the Cavs but since I do
have a longtime coach on the phone line
right here PJ Carlesimo I figured I'd
ask you Rodney hood wouldn't come off
the bench last night midway through the
fourth quarter and there's already some
unnamed Cavs saying they're very upset
about that and that that if Rodney hoods
follow-up answers to the question of
what gives it is not suitable to the
team they're going to suspend him what
what have you ever been in a situation
like that PJ yeah not in playoffs I've
had guys during the
year you know get upset you know
veterans you try and stay away from I
would all due respect to Rodney spending
the league a little while but I don't
put him in that category you know if you
had an older guy on the team you don't
put him in garbage time or stuff like
that you know you'd let the young guys
play you don't disrespect a guy maybe a
guy who'd taken out and starting line up
you know and I don't I didn't even know
about it to be honest with you I was
flying here even with this series I was
in New Orleans and flew out from New
Orleans so I only saw chunks of the game
last night that's totally unacceptable
and this is me not knowing a thing about
it so I should tread softly I'm always
going to get down on a culture side you
know that yep you don't need that any
time even if the coach is wrong it's the
coaches perogative to put somebody in
the game even if he's doing something it
you know like I talked about you try and
tiptoe around that's not the case with
Rodney in the playoffs in at this time
of the year completely unacceptable
that's something that I Got News for you
the players are gonna have an awful lot
to say about that
I'm sure postgame and Lou and and you
know called the almond those guys will
handle it but absolutely the wrong time
to do something like that I don't I
don't know the circumstances yeah okay
I'd like to hear what Rodney said and
why he said it but I can't imagine any
reason why you would do that yeah he's
didn't say anything post game he was one
of the first guys to skedaddle and you
know the only quotes that are involving
and there's our unnamed cat's players
saying that it's unacceptable they're
trying to win a championship it's not
about you et cetera etc but I said what
is the etiquette for this sort of thing
I know you may suspend him you may not
refuse him to go into the game it's
pretty heavy-duty but again different
people that the other thing you need to
know that there may be a precedent I
hate to say that but there may be a
precedent maybe somebody else did this
early in a year last year or something
like that and this is what they did they
find him they did suspend him they
didn't suspend him so we will deal with
it they'll do what they want but I also
think that Lou
Taron Lou is really good because he
brings the players perspective but he's
got a lot of old time in him even though
it was a player you know he was a
blue-collar player for a lot of years
he paid his dues as an assistant coach
most of that time with Doc Rivers he
will sense what the players feel about
this and I guarantee you there and I'll
be shocked if the players aren't really
offended and really upset at this and
and I hate to say it Rodney's not a
ten-year cab he's somebody that you know
came on board this year so I would think
he'll be dealt with fairly severely well
I'm the Chris Brockman my producer is
obviously very fluid you have an update
on this in the last couple minutes
yeah ESPN has Rodney hood apologizing to
Coby Altman so and that he feels awful
about the situation so well we should
let me ask you this PJ cuz the other I
guess story to come out of last night or
at least the aftermath of last night is
that the Raptors get demolished again by
the Cavs that LeBron sweeps them again
and that it's the same cast again and
that you're not going to change the
players but the coach how much do you
think lines up at the feet of Dwayne
Casey and how much do you think is
deserved well be a so a lot of it will
end up at the feet of Dwayne Casey I
think very little bit some yeah I mean
we're a coach to get that's what you get
paid for in this league there's only 30
jobs you paid a lot of money but case
knowing case the way I do having covered
them a lot including two games in the
Washington series so just recently he's
done an unbelievable job I think you
started this question by saying the cast
stays the same that's the point the cast
is the same I loved Masai Ujiri I think
he's done a great job as general manager
there but you're asking me I how good a
coach is Dwayne Casey and how good a job
as he done near the top in both
categories he's excellent he's done a
remarkable job there
the problem isn't Dwayne Casey the
problem is the roster and Dwayne in case
you didn't put the roster together so
here we go with the old NBA front office
and everybody let's change coaches come
on guys he's done great with different
rosters why don't you guys do a better
job putting the roster together instead
of trying to blame grand Cate the way in
Casey but what's going on to Serrano so
what what would you change if you were
the grocery shopping I don't know know
because I'm not conversant with there
trash I'm begging off but it but you
know I'm saying they may be at a
crossroads where hey we've had this a
bulk of this roster together for a while
now and it isn't it isn't work and so
we're gonna have to make a big move we
got to take one of our valuable pieces
that can get something else back and we
got to change it up we have to change up
but their bench played so well for them
all year rich it was unbelievable but
those guys did a great job and bleeped
all those guys picking up CJ Miles was a
great thing
I loved amar drew that back court to
rosenlaui you know we could just talk
about all the pluses what you know why
they're so good
their biggest problem is Cleveland
honestly you know at the time remember
the game back when Philly was playing
Cleveland and I thought it was huge for
Philly Boston to be on that other side
and to avoid Toronto would have been so
much better off on the other side and
not meet in Cleveland until the finals
but still hoping somebody else beat them
because they've got a major major road
block with the Cavaliers why it is I
don't know but they really have a I
think confidence problem playing against
the Cavs more so anybody you should have
a confidence problem playing against
LeBron but I think Toronto has that more
than just about anybody we had them late
in the year they played in Cleveland
twice late in the year got beat both
games they really have a problem and the
road the road to the Eastern Conference
Finals goes through Cleveland I'm sorry
more than anything that's not that's
Toronto's main problem right now but if
your Messiah if your MLS either you know
Maple Leaf Sports & Entertainment that
runs that team
it isn't acceptable you know they think
they've got a team they had the best
record in the east one of the best in
the entire NBA best home record in the
entire NBA they expected to be in the
big finals not in the Eastern Conference
final they expected to be in the NBA
Finals no changes are coming I think it
would be terribly unfair if it's Dwane
Casey's involved in those changes so
Rich Eisen show weekdays at noon eastern
on audience